brothers and sisters and dear friends
i've come to central london today for a
very specific reason i'm going to go and
visit the homeless people and tell them
about what's going on in yemen syria and
other parts of the world where we're
trying to provide 500 000 meals for them
is the homeless going to give towards it
because they have
near to nothing or are they more
generous than me and you and decide to
give something that might be half the
world for all their wealth let's go and
find out follow me
assalamualaikum guys so i'm here with
what's your name my name is dino dino my
name is ali nice to meet you do you know
i was talking to you about if you
remember about the situation in yemen so
where are you from originally
my family was born in romania
my parents yeah i was born in vietnam
okay so the situation in yemen there's a
war going on and because of war there's
been some embargo and you know um
boycott etc so now there is no food
going there there are people literally
starving to death now i know your
situation is also not good you know but
here at least we can find something to
eat people there are literally starving
so i wanted to ask if there's anything
that you would like to give
with your own discretion towards the
yemeni because whatever you give me i
will i'm gonna go around to all the
homeless people today and take whatever
it is two pounds three pounds whatever
and give that towards the donation the
aim behind this is to show people that
people like yourself who do not have
much if you can give they should also
give so it's up to you whatever you want
to give five p 10 p it's up to you if
you want to if you want to give that is
yeah so yeah
well
for me it's very difficult to give
someone because i got nothing exactly i
got nothing exactly if you're opera if
you're not totally understandable
exactly exactly but even if you had like
5p
even if it's five pence
yeah so do you mind if we if we
like okay here we go let's let's not
miss the opportunity you don't have any
like if you give that 10 p or 5p
if you want if you want if you don't if
there's anything you would like to give
it's totally up to you
like even even if it's 10p
yeah yeah yeah thank you you know what
look that's 45 p.m no thank you thank
you you know
no no no no of course i really
appreciate that you know the thing is
here guys the importance this he doesn't
even have much and 45 pence yeah and
this means so much because to someone
like him who doesn't have anything for
him to give this
okay guys so basically what's your name
by the way
andy so we're here with andy uh we're
just talking to him explaining what
we're doing and as we were speaking to
ask permission if we can film obviously
he's now there you go okay look there
you go look if you want a piece of bread
you've got a piece of bread yeah let's
put no water
because the water in time is going like
that and it's coming back exactly
exactly and that's what we believe in
islam i'm a muslim
we believe what you give whatever you do
yes it's coming back to you do the right
things and come back to you yes the
wrong things yeah come back to you yes
exactly do the right things yeah exactly
no thank you man
do you know thank you very much this i'm
gonna put this
towards the charity inshallah she's look
we said to him look we said to him even
if you give 5p
andy is homeless you can see the
situation
but look how generous he is he's given
two pounds yeah i said look even if you
can give 5p or 10p and this means so
much guys because if you think about it
this could be maybe half of his wealth
or even all of his wealth basically we
started a fundraiser we've raised around
nearly 80 000 pounds so anything
anything that's given towards it we're
trying to reach 100 but this will
motivate people you know
to give yeah but thank you look i i
really really appreciate the fact that
and and by the way once we've done the
video i'm going to come and show you
exactly what you've given i'm going to
i'm going to transfer this straight from
my account
to there because it has to be bank
transfer so somebody gave 45p and you
gave 2 pounds and thank you very much it
really means so much brothers and
sisters we went out there to a couple of
people who are homeless subhanallah and
we asked them and subhanallah we went to
about three or four and two of them gave
something subhanallah which is two
pounds 45 p and that to me means a lot
of brothers and sisters and if they can
do it why can't we do it subhanallah
sisters and we need this to go to yemen
syria afghanistan for people to be fed
basic humanitarian needs brothers and
sisters
subhanallah food water that is all they
need brother and sister inshallah 60
pounds feeds a family for an entire
month you guys spend 60 pounds on the
steak guys go to the link and give it
inshallah may i bless you guys hope you
enjoyed this video this is the reason i
did it inshallah mel accept it from us
and you make the most out of it because
today might be the last day of ramadan
sisters and we might not see the next
one assalamu alaikum